[Applaudissements]
sous un tonnerre d'applaudissements
le film parasites qui avait déjà
remporté la palme d'or à cannes a
conquis hollywood pour vrai ça a été un
peu comme quand le canadien a gagné la
coupe stanley en 1993 parce que c'est un
cinéma que qui me passionne tellement le
réalisateur de parasites bodjongo à
l'écouté au passage un total de quatre
statues et la voisine a mis un mot de
passe à son réseau pour cent à la fois
dramatique et comique sur la misère
d'une famille au chômage qui s'incruste
insidieusement dans la maison d'une
famille riche
là je pense que ce film là vient toucher
quelque chose d'assez universel c'est à
dire la lutte des classes comme à regret
maintien scorsese influencé par le
cinéma américain et par le cinéma
français bonnes gens qu a réalisé
plusieurs films depuis les 25 dernières
années dont on déjà moteur et le
thriller fantastique dit host
[Musique]
le style du cinéaste sud coréen mais
beaucoup pour réalisateur québécois fait
le falardeau la première fois j'ai vu un
film de ce réseau tor c'était d'euros ce
qui est un film avec un monstre j'étais
dans une petite salle à paris et j'ai
mais qu'est ce que je regarde là il y
avait un sens de l'humour une
désinvolture et tous ces films parlent
de la famille sucer partage vos pas ce
diplôme comme une contrefaçon
le triomphe de parasites à la cérémonie
des oscars a convaincu certains
cinéphiles de voir le film dès le
lendemain tous qui ont garni je me suis
dit bon mais finalement je veux y aller
et qu'elle imaginait sûrement différent
là différentes façons de voir les choses
j'ai regretté de ne pas l'avoir vu avant
la grande question maintenant
après le succès de parasites tourné en
coréen est ce que le réalisateur
bandjoun au sort a tenté de tourner
davantage en anglais que bong joon ho
reste encore et et continue de faire des
films en coréen ici nous fait depuis mai
radio canada montréal
[Applaudissements]